all right it's caught in a Ferrari in
Ferris Bueller's Day Off caught in a
Boston speed caught in a mayor's office
in Spin City and so much more including
HBO's succession that just wrapped up
season 1 you should go download it or
watch it stream it on HBO now HBO Go
iTunes Google Play other retailers
already been picked up for season 2
because it's an incredible show an
incredible cast including Alan ruck good
to see you sir thanks thanks for having
you but this is a fun show where what do
you get when you see this script and see
the arc of your character I don't to get
too deep into it for anybody hasn't seen
this show about a dysfunctional family
around Brian Cox who's kind of I guess
like a Rupert Murdoch type character
yeah something like that you know so
when you see your character blossom if
you will in a way the way that it does
it's kind of a license to steal
I mean parts like this from me come
around maybe once every 10 years or 15
years and it's just an individual who's
really damaged has a big wall of money
around him and is really not responsible
to anybody or anything and all these
people anything can come out of their
mouths because there's no repercussions
you know they they they March to a
different set of rules or none at all
not at all yes certainly when the
familial bonds don't appear to be
there's no there's not much hug you know
everybody wants daddys love it's just
not coming around
you know mmm it's not it's not readily
available so I just wanted to point that
out because I don't want to make it seem
like you're you're a damaged individual
because you're a Browns fan deep down
inside Alan right you're I was born in
Cleveland I was born in Cleveland when I
was a boy I used to watch the Browns
with my dad it was something that we did
together and I told you earlier that we
would be Browns fans until they choked
and then we would become Pittsburgh fans
at that point because you know there was
the days of Pittsburgh and Dallas back
then right so now to hear that that that
that normally wouldn't be you know
acceptable but I guess you know
obviously back then when you're rooting
for a team like Cleveland and but we had
relatives in Pittsburgh you know so
something we could it's so it's it's
it's it is close I mean
that's where you flew into this this
past probably try yeah well you try to
Brian getting to the Hall of Fame we go
to Wall of Fame every year though good
Canton and anytime somebody from the
Pittsburgh area gets inducted you see
you know what if Jim Kelly or when
Montana went in and obviously you know
Namath those guys from the Pittsburgh
area you can see a large Pittsburgh
contingent town contingent yeah yeah so
dry river people so you you would give
your sort of brown slash Steeler fan
yeah that wasn't my own how many people
just automatically think you're a Red
Wings fan based on your character I'll
ask about that that was something that
Hughes made up that was some backstory
about Cameron he just figured that the
the relationship with the father was so
bad that he had a really good
relationship with his grandfather who is
never showed up in the picture right
grandfather lived in Detroit went to
games with the grandfather and that's
why he wore that Jersey said had nothing
to do with if you had a choice did they
give you a choice at all I no no no no
no no I wasn't that consulted or not
what about the wardrobes you have chosen
a Browns Jersey if probably not probably
done
red is cooler okay that's a sweater yes
a in hockey so do people assume you're a
Cubs fan because of that feeling I am
okay you are yeah because I went to the
University of Illinois and right after
school I moved up to Chicago and then
this was back in the days when there
were no lights in Wrigley Field and
everything was like a picnic you had to
go in the afternoon and you sat in the
bleachers and ate smoky links and you
know watch the cubbies and right yeah
and so the up and down and and finally
the the eventual triumph I was in
Chicago I was working on a show called
The Exorcist we were in Chicago a couple
years ago when they when they won and
and what was that five million people
it's a I don't know where that came from
from everywhere from everywhere from
everywhere and and completely civil I
mean it was just a great celebration of
baseball and love so you're not a red
wings fan but you are in fact a Cubs fan
it's true well it's been great for you
to be in town for something like that to
happen for me were filming we were
filming and we would they were the you
know the crew was watching while we were
filming and they'd be like
rose it could make any noise because and
then cut and everybody go wild go crazy
yeah yeah man I mean that that that is
truly you know once-in-a-lifetime
situation it's interesting that you call
succession once every 10 15 years roll
for you I mean yeah there's some pretty
iconic stuff here Alan I mean I'm not
I've been lucky yeah I'm really lucky
yeah being on that bus and speed that
was fun so it was a fun gig did you ever
come across Dennis Hopper cuz obviously
this wasn't on the bus no no I didn't
where I saw I saw him once at the
premier party and he did really didn't
know who I was he went like you know he
didn't know no no that was a fun job the
105 freeway had just been completed
right here right here but had not yet
been opened so we made a deal with the
state that Fox pictures made a deal that
that was our back lot for six weeks and
we had about a half a dozen different
buses that did different tricks and it
was just you know so you broke in the
105 freeway yeah we did yeah yeah you
gave it a dry run yeah we did with many
buses Keanu Reeves yeah and the 105 yeah
and many bosses what was it like on the
set with John Hughes for you he you know
he was a complicated guy he was he was
sort of a genius I had met him once in
Chicago a couple years before Ferris
Bueller he was gonna do the Breakfast
Club as an indie and I went in and I
read for him on that and then he met
Molly Ringwald on that picture on that
uh during that time and he wrote sixteen
Candles for her over weekend over a
weekend like that and then so then I did
this play in New York with Matthew
Broderick and he was offered Ferris
Bueller and I auditioned for the casting
people and I went back and I read for
John with Matthew so I already knew John
a little bit Matthew and I were already
friends I was just a bit of luck from
Biloxi blues but a Biloxi blues yeah
it's so interesting what part did you
read for in the Breakfast Club
bender it wasn't I was not right for it
at all the judge
just Nelson yeah yeah yeah I mean we're
just not enough of a bad guy is that
what you're saying like the you know I
don't I don't kind of have that face you
know I'm saying I don't I don't
intimidate you're more anybody you're
more Cameron than that I don't
intimidate my kids nobody yeah I know I
had I had well and I won one shot at
being a reality TV host of yeah well
years ago and the show required me to be
mysterious one and done I don't mean
like I'm not no mystery that yeah I
guess me you know so I have a couple of
questions from your IMDB as well as
Internet we usually do here with a
celebrity guests all right celebrity
true or false here on the Rich Eisen
show our first question for you sir you
were 29 years old when you were filming
Ferris Bueller's Day Off to her Falls
this is true you were you were 29 years
old well when I was actually 19 when I
was 19 I look like a fetus so just
progressed yeah yeah I'm knocking on
Kizer hood store right now it's 29 yeah
I would never have guessed that
well Broderick was 25 the only one that
was really a teenager was Mia Sarah who
I think it just turned 18 maybe she was
19 but she was actually a teenager the
rest of us we're all in our 20s and
wasn't that the publicity lady from
Paramount found out how old I was she
almost choked on her own spit is that
right yeah because she was like oh oh oh
we'll tell people you're 25 that's okay
cuz Matthews 25 that's okay okay Wow are
you scared and so you know no Tiger Beat
Magazine for me it's all worked out you
know when I would be doing highlights
with Mike with my compadres Steve
Mariucci and Deion Sanders on the NFL
Network whenever Adrian Peterson carried
the ball we would go Peterson homage to
you whose voice were you doing and when
you were talking in Ferris Bueller's Day
Off okay Matthew and I had done this
play Biloxi blues and we were directed
by this wonderful guy who since passed
away named gene Sachs
he was 65 then
and we drove him crazy because we were
always screwing around we were cutting
up and he gets so mad at us he were
afraid we're gonna give him a heart
attack as you get real red in the face
and say I don't believe his soldiers I
don't believe it gonna go diet Italy you
know and so he was said to me yeah I
need a voice give me a dad voice an
authoritarian voice right and so I
didn't tell Matthew what I was going to
do because Matthew was constantly
walking around backstage
imitating gene so that was me imitating
Matthew imitating gene and I just sprung
it on him just to see if I get a laugh
out of him you know and then it worked
Rudy yeah yeah yeah did you ad-lib the
pardon my french don't do the whole line
here but did you ad-lib that the part my
you know Hughes this is a fun way to
work when you he was very confident the
same way we work on succession you do it
as scripted once and then they'll say we
have some other lines you want to try
these you want to try these and you know
an additional takes and then usually
there's one take where they just say
make it up just give us whatever you
know so so yeah Hugh say pardon my
french call him an a-hole you know I
mean you know shouting lines at me you
know it's a fun way to work it's amazing
it second true or false celebrity true
or false here for for Alan ruck the
Ferrari 25 GT California that your
characters dad owned was not actually a
Ferrari in real life true or false
that's true they were crap they were kit
cars because we couldn't at that time
that car if anybody had wanted to rent
it to us and this is such a long time
ago it was probably worth about $400,000
then okay and so we couldn't even first
of all you have to find somebody that's
willing to rent it to you right and then
the insurance just to keep it still on a
movie set was astronomical so they said
we're never going to be able to afford
this so they had some fiberglass
replicas made they were put on Mustang
chassis and they they gave us a lot of
trouble there's one scene where we go to
collect the car after we've had our big
day and the guys bring the car down in
the parking garage they turn the car off
we have a little bit of dialogue and we
go to start it up and take off 16 takes
because it would come down they turn it
off and then we'd get in the car
not going anywhere you know and it drove
everybody crazy so when we sent the
there were three there was one that was
souped up for the stunt guys there was
the one that we used and there was the
one that was just a shell that we sent
out the window and when we did that the
whole crew just erupted and cheers yeah
you know enough last one for you Emilio
Estevez was originally offered the role
of Cameron is that true this is true and
I think they wanted Anthony Michael Hall
to play Ferris but both of those guys
had done well Mike Anthony Michael Hall
he'd done maybe four movies with Hughes
in them points not a bunch he wanted to
move on and I think Emilio was offered
repo man remember that picture horse
yeah and so they wanted to go do
different things and so then they they
picked Broderick and then I wrote his
coattails well as a 22 that picture
there's a 29 year old and then now
succession Allen Rock what is it like
working with Brian Cox I'm such a big
fan of his man I mean everybody on this
show is incredibly funny incredibly
talented they're all sweethearts which
is great because we're a bunch of
bastards even kieran culkin
yeah I mean yeah could not be more wrong
no he's he's a sociopath on the show
right but just a funny and lovable witch
it balances everything out you know and
adds a little bit of that humanity seeps
through all the wretchedness you know so
maybe it's some you know people were
complaining at the beginning of the
season there's nobody that that's
likable right nobody to root for but
maybe after a while which sort of will
grow on people you know but Brian Cox's
I love him you know he's world-class
actor he's incredibly generous and I
find this with with people that are very
top of sort of the heap they tend to be
very generous and they're all about the
storytelling they're just there because
they love to do what they do and that's
all it is we're just telling stories you
know and no drama the drama is in front
of the camera it's not off stage which
is the way you want it of course an HBO
succession again the first season is
already done airing on HBO but you can
catch it on HBO now HBO Go iTunes Google
Play other retailers already renewed for
second season congratulations thanks
buddy you got it Alan
Kieron the Rich Eisen show Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience